it's a pretty scary new warning that
comes from border patrol sources have
told Fox that agents are now being told
to be on the lookout for improvised
explosive devices IEDs the kind we heard
so much about in Iraq and in Afghanistan
but these are just south of our border
in Mexico in the middle of this uh
border crisis that we're watching so
they discovered 10 of them uh on the
over that southern border just after the
border patrol arrested someone with a
loaded AK-47 and a lot of ammo in the
Tucson area in Arizona so what's going
on here let's bring in Tom homman former
acting ice director and Fox News
contributor Tom just spent three days
with the border of Patrol uh at the
Texas border Tom always good to have you
with us so what is your reaction to this
news of these IED explosive devices and
also these this
AK-47 uh confiscation that happened on
our side of the Border what's going on
on
here well it's don't surprise me the the
criminal cartels of Mexico they've been
using IED since 2010 against military
forces but now you see them on the
border and there's there's a a good
reason you see it on the border because
the criminal cartels of Mexico are
making record amount of money in Alien
smuggling sex trafficking women and
children and drug smuggling because most
of the border patrol is off the line the
process of this humanitarian crisis the
self-inflicted wound of this
humanitarian crisis so most AG Ro line
be it wide open for drug smuggling
trafficking and Aly smuggling what's
happening right now reason they see this
on the border right now there's the
senol cartels are two factions of the
senol cartel that are fighting on each
other for control the plazas the area
their areas of operation it's those
chapitos which are the sons of Chapo
Guzman who have in prison and El Mayo
they're fighting each over fighting over
the the the the plazas for control
because they're making record amounts of
money so they're using the car bombs and
IEDs against each other and the problem
is that that stuff's going to flow over
to the United States already has the
Seno cartel now has presence in most of
our major cities in the United States so
that vus will certainly spill over to
the United States yeah so the way you're
explaining it um obviously this is the
new business right trafficking people
not new but this is now their dominant
business and the cartels essentially
control this border so they're fighting
over the turf on that border with the
same kind of things they've used in the
drug wars for a long time now we
understand that obviously there's
increasing political pressure on the
White House about this situation the
president doesn't like to talk about it
very much but there are negotiations
going on with this deal over the Ukraine
and Israel money that would include
border situation uh solution attempts as
well um and we're understand that
they're getting a little bit closer it
might have something to do with changing
some of the Asylum rules for one thing
and maybe implementing something along
the lines of title title 42 again if
that is what they conclude and that
happens what difference does that make
Tom unless hr2 the legislation that
Congress uh the house passed which is
the strongest border legislation I've
seen in my career if hr2 passed it will
have it'll have an effect on the
smuggling come across the border but the
cartels we need to take the cartels out
the Mexican Government is has been
unsuccessful in 30 years and they have
you know the criminal cartels Mexico not
only have operational control of our
border they have operational control of
a large part of Mexico what despite what
they do with the Border situation again
hr2 should be uh implemented in its full
full the full effect but we still got to
address what would that do Tom just to
clarify for people who are listening to
you saying hr2 tell them what it
is pretty much is if you look at it's
pretty much the Trump policies it's
pretty much talking about remain in
Mexico program the Asylum rules end The
Catch and Release it's this it's the
stuff that the Trump Administration we
did that that you know uh results in the
most secure board we ever had so we know
that we know the policy work so this
should be easy you know to negotiate a a
situation where we know what policies
work let's do that even the Democrats
should say right we had the lowest
illegal immigration in 45 years the drug
flow is low let's take this hr2 which is
basically the Trump policies and put it
in place yeah well they undid pretty
much everything that was in place
whether it was working or not uh and we
heard President Biden on the debate
stage make it very clear what his
intention was he said if you you should
come now is the time you should come and
cross the border and now we see on the
right hand side of your screen that's
Eagle Pass Texas but you see these live
pictures every day uh with the help of
our drone cameras down there in our
coverage and with the the uh input from
Tom homman thank you Tom always good to
have you with
us thanks for having I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis